tenemos el número 35 que son tres
decenas porque tenemos un tres en el
lugar de las decenas aunque este es el
lugar de las decenas aquí están nuestras
tres decenas
y tenemos un 5 en el lugar de las
unidades unidades y vemos estas cinco
unidades representadas por aquí tenemos
5 unidades
así es que 35 son tres decenas y cinco
unidades que hay tres decenas y cinco
unidades ahora lo que queremos hacer en
este vídeo es a 35 restarle 8
así es que te recomiendo que le pongas
una pausa del vídeo e intentes calcular
cuánto es 35 menos 8
bueno vamos a pensarlo paso por paso
tenemos 5 unidades y queremos restar 8
unidades pero pues no sabemos cómo
quitar 8 unidades si sólo tenemos 5
aunque si tenemos 5 unidades
podríamos quitar esas 5 unidades pero
luego ahí ya se nos acabaron las
unidades y todavía nos faltaría quitar
otras 3 unidades
entonces cómo le vamos a hacer para
quitar 8 unidades y bueno aquí es donde
es útil las reagrupaciones ok porque no
sólo tenemos 5 unidades en realidad
tenemos 35 tenemos 3 grupos de 10
unidades y después tenemos estas otras 5
unidades
así es que por qué no tomamos uno de
estos grupos de 10 unidades que en este
momento se encuentran en el lugar de las
decenas y lo re agrupamos en el lugar de
las unidades
si es que porque no tomamos este grupo
de 10 unidades y en lugar de expresar lo
en el lugar de las decenas lo pasamos al
lugar de las unidades y ahora en el
lugar de las unidades pues una decena
son 10 unidades cierto aquí estos 10
cuadritos los vamos a poner por acá
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 listo aquí está nuestra
decena entonces qué es lo que acaba de
pasar pues tomé una de las decenas ahora
tenemos dos decenas en lugar de tres y
esa decena la paz se al lugar de las
unidades aunque antes teníamos cinco
unidades pero ahora tenemos otras diez
unidades que conformaban a esa decena y
cinco más diez es 15 que ahí tenemos 15
unidades y dos decenas y ahora sí ya
podemos quitar muy fácilmente ocho
unidades aunque quitamos uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho unidades
que estamos quitando estas ocho unidades
y que nos va a quedar ahora pues nos
quedaron dos decenas
dos decenas y cuántas unidades pues uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
unidades siete unidades ahora como lo
haríamos si no quisiéramos dibujar todos
estos cuadritos pues bueno lo que
haríamos es decir ok tengo tres decenas
y cinco unidades que es donde empezamos
al principio y queremos restarle 8 pero
como el 8 es más grande que el 5
entonces vamos a tomar una de estas
decenas tomamos una decena y entonces
nos quedan dos decenas y la vamos a
convertir a unidades y una decena son 10
unidades
así es que esas 10 unidades más estas 5
unidades son
15 unidades y ahora sí ya podemos
restarle 8
15 8 pues 15 menos 87 y bueno eso es lo
que vimos por aquí aunque hay 15 menos 8
son 7 después de restar estas ocho
unidades nos quedan siete unidades y
bueno pues teníamos dos decenas entonces
nos quedan dos decenas y siete unidades
o sea 27